i have had ups and downs there is no
shame
no shame in seeking help right now uh
for all of that anxiety and all of the
intensity
we are holding as a nation and as a
global community so much pain and
heaviness
well sarah it's so good to see you i
wish it was in person but it's good to
see you over zoom
at least see you too katie it's called
christmas in vienna
i loved it i'm a sap i love hallmark
i didn't expect to bump into you again
i'm sorry to disappoint
um what was it like shooting in vienna
was it right before
kobet kind of hit yeah i mean
it was so magical i got to we got to go
to vienna
when the whole world goes to vienna
which is right at christmas time we were
there in december
so it was already magically
lit for christmas with all the lights
and the christmas markets and we
shot in in schonbrunn palace inside of
the palace
we shot um inside of saint stephen's
cathedral which was already decked out
for christmas i mean that's the thing we
got to literally just
plop ourselves in the middle of this
totally incredible wonderland and shoot
we shot in the middle of
actual crowds like actual tourists in
those christmas markets i mean every
language you can imagine you're hearing
as you're
walking past um so it was
truly magical in every way and i got to
bring my husband to vienna
and we got to have this like some really
beautiful romantic times we got to hear
some of the most
the most incredible classical music i've
ever heard in my life
we got to go to the music hall in the
opera house and
it was nuts it was so amazing
why your parents do sound great they
have this saying
that love is learning the song in
someone's heart
and singing it when they need it most
well i like that
how does your husband feel watching you
shoot these romantic
magical hallmark scenes yeah you know
for him it was just such a treat
actually to get to come with me
that um and and this he you know we've
been together for
20 years maybe even longer 21 years now
like it's he he proposed to me while i
was playing juliet in romeo and juliet
you know so like he's used to this this
is
this is old hat to him he totally gets
it it's
it's just been part of our rhythm
forever for me
for me to do these things you guys also
homeschooling
the kids right now with all of this
yes except you know thank thank the lord
our incredible nanny who's been with us
since my son who's now eight was
18 months old she um she's been with us
the whole time
was it challenging for the kids at first
i mean not being able to go and really
see
more than we need to like be in an
actual classroom
absolutely and and especially for hannah
because
hannah graduated from kindergarten
in the spring and there was no
graduation and he really missed being in
school
but they have they have this like
magical community of friends
here on the block that they see go out
and play with at least twice a day
so kind of we feel like we are so
lucky on the street we're on it's a
cul-de-sac so they ride their bikes and
they scooter and they
run around and play hide-and-seek and
jump out and scare one another you know
it's just like
yeah how it was for us when we were
growing up yeah
it sounds like you really figured it out
and you really have become mom of the
year
in dealing with this so my hat goes off
to you for that
um you also celebrated was it the 40th
birthday
it was the 40th how how was it to
celebrate
amid everything and how does it feel to
to get to start a new decade so
um yeah i i had a lot of anxiety leading
up to it i think
there's oh especially this
industry that we're in
just fear fear swirling around
as you get older as a woman
you don't feel that way when you're a
man getting older in this industry
but as a woman you do and i think
that combined with it being such a slow
year and everything
being at a standstill yeah i had a lot
of anxiety
walking into it and and and felt like oh
there's like
[Music]
i i wish that i hadn't gotten goods like
us a nail in a coffin
you know like you've had 40 year old
lady
which which is ridiculous like why do we
do that
i don't know why we do that well it's
like it's almost like there's like
all these pre notions about like what
you should be doing
and i feel like you're right with the
industry and roles and
you're wondering like what where do i
fit
how do i work and i think but but i will
say you know they're so
i've been going in for so many really
fantastic multi-layered interesting
characters so like
i i didn't need to be afraid basically i
didn't need to be afraid and once i
actually got
to the day it was beautiful my husband
secretly
arranged this like incredible scenario
where he
reached out to all the people in my life
in all the different seasons of my life
like high school friends
and and and family friends who i grew up
vacationing with when i was like a tiny
child
and had them write letters or videos
and send pictures of memories so i i
woke up to this like
amazing book full of letters some
handwritten some
printed out tons of pictures of people
recounting memories with me
and um and the opening page was sarah
drew land for beloved for 40 years i'm
literally gonna cry thinking about it
that's like the most thoughtful
but especially with everything going on
it's like
what a good reminder of like all the
love in your life that you've had and
just
yeah you know it's like a glimmer of oh
my god are you emotional
do you before i let you go i mean do you
have a message to fans right now who are
having a hard
a hard time going through this i feel
like you are such a beacon of
of hope and light
oh man um
i think i think the i mean this is
this is a message for myself too i mean
i i go
i go into spirals of darkness
in the midst of this it's brutal it like
what's happening
is so hard and i feel like i've been
talking to a bunch of friends lately who
are feeling are having anxiety attacks
for the first time in their lives
and are feeling depressed for the first
time in their lives
and are like contemplating seeking
medication
and and things like that and feeling
guilty about it and i guess
one of the big things that i would say
is dude i i
have i have had a prescription for a
long time
in my life i have had ups and downs
there is no shame
no shame in seeking help right now uh
for all of that anxiety and all of the
intensity
we are holding as a nation and as a
global community
so much pain and heaviness so much
and some so much more than others but
then even
even people who are doing better in
terms of like
they still have a roof over their heads
there are other
emotional things i mean that that come
in that are so intense so i just
feel like we all need to collectively
give ourselves a break
and and allow ourselves to feel the
sadness because it's there and
pretending it's not there is not
gonna help us heal and move through it
um and to just not judge ourselves
in the midst of this and also just the
reminder that
there will be an end to this like the
sun will come out again
we will not be in this tunnel forever
you know
you brought up something so important
and that's mental health
and not to like feel ashamed about
seeking help
and i feel like the more people talk
about it the
less stigma there is around it do you
i mean how do you handle like your
anxiety and like when you've had those
correct moments during the pandemic
like what gets you through that so i
have been
pretty religiously doing yoga for the
last year and a half
um and and i will say i had
a uh a really rough couple weeks
where i woke up in a panic attack like
every single morning
and i would find that as soon as i did
some yoga
and and like got the breath moving in my
body
i realized oh no i can breathe i can
breathe i just have to actually
concentrate on it once i can concentrate
on it and let it come in
and let it go out and let it i i realize
oh it's all loosening up it's all
loosening up
i also have a prescription for
anti-anxiety specifically for when
i get panicky and and i've had i've had
that prescription
my entire adult life and it took me
it took me a while to actually seek help
because i really
really used to think that it was some
sort of failure
on my part to need help that i couldn't
pray my way through it or find the
courage or strength
internally to figure it out and it's
like now
i look at those things as tools like
thank god thank god that tool is
available to us right now hallelujah
thank you thank you for providing that
doctors and scientists
so now i don't have any shame associated
with that
um so i will take medication if i need
it i will do my yoga
um i will pray uh i will get outside
and get feel some sunshine on my face
just breathing outside air
that really does start to settle things
for me um
and the other one the other big thing is
is writing down gratitude
just very small even the smallest
tiniest things
just then you can when you see it on a
page you go
okay all right yeah there's still
so many things to be grateful for
[Music]
you